[Musik]
ist ein altes russisches Sprichwort das
ist in fast allen anderen Sprachen auch
gibt auf Deutsch können wir es als wenn
die Katze aus dem Haus ist tanzen die
Mäuse auf dem Tisch wie jeder weiß hat
sich Russland also die Katze im
existiertischen Raum in der Ukraine in
einem Kampf unter Einsatz aller Krallen
und Szene eingelassen worauf im
russischen Hinterhof in Mittelasien und
dem Kaukasus nun die Mäuse tanzen es gab
bereits einen kleinen aber sehr heftigen
Grenzkrieg zwischen dir dieses Teil und
Tadschikistan und als ob wir in diesem
Jahr nicht schon genug kriegt hätten ist
auch der schon seit über 30 Jahren
stehende bergkarabach-konflikt wieder
aufgeflogen
aserbaidan startet weitreichende
Angriffe gegen Armenien da der kremme
derzeit nicht in der Lage ist zwischen
den beiden streiten zu vermitteln oder
wie im letzten Jahr mit einem
Militäreinsatz für Ruhe zu sorgen ist
Aserbaidschan wieder in den Ring
gestiegen diesmal allerdings mit dem
Novum das ist sogar direkt armenisches
Staatsgebiet angegriffen hat und nicht
wie bisher nur die auf eigenem
Staatsgebiet liegende Enklave Bergheim
und das ist schon ansatzweise ein
Problem für Europa warum weil
Aserbaidschan Spaß an die Europäische
Union liefert und nicht nur das der
begehrte Rohstoff von dort ist eine
solide Alternative zu russischem Gas
aber nun überfällt also auch dieser
Gaslieferant weil ebenso sein
Nachbarland und das mögen die Europäer
ja eigentlich gar nicht so sehr
inzwischen haben Armenien Aserbaidschan
zwar einen Waffenstillstand ausgehandelt
wieder einmal aber eines ist damit schon
bewiesen russland hat nicht mehr den
Einfluss den es noch vor ein paar
Monaten in der Region hatte
ja liebe visualpolitik Zuschauer der
Krieg in der Ukraine verändert alles
aber wo ist Krisen gibt gibt es auch
Chancen nicht nur auf der Energieebene
sondern auch politische Chancen der
Europäischen Union öffnet sich gerade
eine Chance Zentralasien etwas in ihren
Einflussbereich zu ziehen und es nicht
anderen Großmächten zu überlassen und
aufgepasst in diesem Fall meine ich
jetzt nicht mehr Russland der
chinesische Präsidentin versucht Türen
in Zentralasien zu öffnen während
Russland durch den ukraine-krieg
geschwächt ist der Punkt ist das Europa
anfängt Schritte in ein Zentralasiens
Unternehmen aber wie ihr euch vorstellen
könnt hinterlassen außenpolitische
anwandlungsversuche mit Diktaturen aller
Art keinen guten Eindruck bei den
Europäern oft genug schafft man sich
damit ja nur wieder neue Probleme man
hört es in Brüssel nicht gerne wenn man
sagt dass zu Europas besten Freunden
Herrscher Clans gehören die im Post
sowjetischen Raum in ein oder anderen
Staat privatisiert das heißt sich unter
den Nagel gerissen haben so etwa die
alias aus Parcours oder der neue
Diktator von Turkmenistan der just der
Sohn des vorherigen Diktators ist ja
genau das war der Typ mit diesen extrem
schwer auszusprechenden Namen aber ich
versuche es trotzdem
mohammedos wir haben ihn euch schon mal
in einem anderen Video vorgestellt er
nannte sich akadak der Beschützer und er
ließ sich wie schon sein Amtsvorgänger
der Turkmen Baschi in der Hauptstadt
mächtige goldene Statuen errichten
übrigens nicht nur von sich sondern auch
noch von seinem Hund just nach erscheint
unseres Videos im März hat an die
Amtsgeschäfte an seinen Sohn übertragen
der neue starke Mann dieser knallharten
Diktatur hinter vergoldeten
operettenkulisten heißt nun also Serdar
gurbankuljevic Verdi mohamedov hurra
unfallfrei ausgesprochen und das gleich
beim ersten Mal aber okay mal abgesehen
von diesen kompliziert auszusprechenden
Namen sicherlich ist ist für Europa
grundsätzlich besser in Sachen Erdgas
gleichzeitig von mehreren Bösewichten
abhängig zu sein als noch in einem
einzigen erdschoten und dem aber Achtung
für die ehemaligen Sowjet Republiken ist
es im geopolitischen sondern gar nicht
mal so einfach aus der Umklammerung
Putins herauszukommen wie also kann
Brüssel Zentralasien in seine
Einflusssphäre ziehen könnte es wirklich
von dort billig und stabil Gas bekommen
und zugleich gegen Russland und China
Punkten und ganz am Rande eine andere
Frage welche Probleme entstehen für die
Europäische Union Aserbaidschan Armenien
erneut angreift heute werden wir uns auf
visualpolitik diesen Fragen widmen aber
zuerst werfen wir einmal wieder einen
kleinen Blick ins Geschichtsbuch wobei
diesmal ist es eher das Geographiebuch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
unsere Reise auf der Landkarte beginnen
wir weit weg von Turkmenistan genauer
gesagt 4.500 Kilometer weit weg der
Beginn an einem Ort im Indischen Ozean
über den wir euch auf visualpolitik
schon erzählt haben ich spreche von den
andermalen und Nicobaren einer
Inselgruppe die zu indien gehört und
eine Achillesferse Chinas Essen
[Musik]
verschlingt unermüdlich Ressourcen das
macht Tina gewissermaßen zu einem riesen
auftönernen Füßen in einer Großteil
seiner Öl- und Rohstofflieferungen wie
es durch die Straße von Malaka sollte es
also jemals zu Problemen mit China
kommen könnten seine Rivalen also die
USA und oder Indien die an der mahnen
und Nicobaren Inseln nutzen um die
Schifffahrt über den Indischen Ozean zu
blockieren und China sozusagen an die
Gurgel gehen
deshalb ist Zentralasien für China so
relevant es handelt sich um eine Region
für die sich bis vor kurzem außer
Russland niemand groß interessierte doch
Zentralasien hat viele natürliche
Ressourcen aber wenig Aktivitäten um sie
auszurollen ein gutes Beispiel dafür ist
türkmenistan bei der derzeitigen
Förderrate hat Russland Gasreserven für
58 Jahre und qatare für 144 Jahre aber
dort mindest dann hat Gas für die
nächsten 230 Jahre und das sagt uns
zweierlei ja man hat dort reichlich Gas
aber man beutet es bislang auch nur sehr
zaghaft aus
[Musik]
es braucht nun mal eine Menge
Investitionen und die Förderung auf
einem Gasfeld in Betrieb zu nehmen und
noch mehr um die notwendigen
Infrastruktur für den Export zu
errichten aber natürlich war China schon
immer bereit überall dort wo es
Kohlenwasserstoffe gibt die nötigen Yuan
zu investieren um sie zu fördern schaut
euch dazu diese Karte an die China
Zentralasien Gaspipeline die durch
Usbekistan und Kasachstan verlor
ermöglicht es China seit 2010
gasausdruck ministanz zu beziehen früher
verkaufte drückminister den Großteil
seines Gases an Russland aber in den
letzten Jahren hat sich einiges geändert
doch Minister hat im Jahr 2021 bereits
34 Milliarden Kubikmeter Gas nach Peking
exportiert dreimal so viel wie die 10
Milliarden Kubikmeter die es an Moskau
verkauft hat
ist der wichtigste Gaslieferant für
China auf dem Landweg und der
zweitgrößte insgesamt mehr kommt nur aus
Australien in Form von Flüssiggas
tatsächlich ist die Kapazität der China
transasiengaspipeline von rund 55
Milliarden Kubikmetern pro Jahr derzeit
konkurrenzlos wenn es darum geht China
auf den Landweg mit Gas zu versorgen die
Pipeline namens Kraft Sibiriens die
China aus Russland versorgt wird
voraussichtliche drei Jahren eine
Kapazität von 38 Milliarden Kubikmetern
erreichen also 30% weniger all dies
unterstreicht also die Bedeutung durch
ministanz für China
und wir haben ja alle von Shisha things
letzten Treffen mit Putin in Samarkand
gehört was dabei vielleicht eher
unterging der chinesische Präsident hat
sich auch mit den Staatsoberhaupt in der
15-tal asiatischen Länder getroffen denn
Pekings Interesse an der Regionen und
sein Einfluss dort wächst rasant während
der russische Einfluss parallel abnimmt
und es gibt drei Gründe warum sich
dieser Trend noch verstärken wird der
erste ist dass China nun mal ein
attraktiverer Handelspartner ist als
Russland zweitens will niemand mehr auf
das Verlierer Pferd und dessen loser
Rock gesessen ihr wird schon der mit dem
nackten Oberkörper reitende selbst der
Präsident des Arnum Tadschikistan
erlaubte sich unlängst auf einem Gus
Gipfeltreffen Putin wegen Russland
selbst herrlicher Haltung die Leviten zu
lesen und drittens ist zu
berücksichtigen dass Kasachstan unter
den zentralasiatischen Ländern Ton
angeben in der Region ist und wie wir
euch in einem früheren Video gezeigt
haben distanziert sich Kasachstan
gegenwärtig recht deutlich vom krabbeln
[Musik]
das hat es jetzt wieder getan und zwar
mit einem von Präsident Türkei jetzt
persönlich unterzeichneten Artikel in
politiko im Lieblingsmedium der
Brüsseler Politiker
Kasachstans Präsident wir gehen mit
voller Kraft in Richtung Reform der
wachsende Einfluss Chinas in zentrale
Asien ist jedoch ein Problem für Europa
aber noch mehr für die Vereinigten
Staaten vor allem weil mit der
Vereinnahmung der natürlichen Ressourcen
dieser fünf Länder seitens Pekings die
Möglichkeit zu Blockade der
Energielieferung an China abnimmt und
natürlich will der besten aus
geopolitischer Sicht dass der Status Quo
erhalten bleibt denn es liegt in seinem
Interesse für eine abschreckende
blockadeoption an der Straße von Malaka
zu behalten
[Musik]
es wäre nämlich nicht ausgeschlossen
dass durch Minister sein Erdgas lieber
an Europa verkauft was für den Europäer
auch eine gute Möglichkeit wäre dass nun
ausbleibende Gas aus Russland zu
ersetzen derzeit sucht die Europäische
Kommission ja fieberhaft nach einer
Formel gehst die 150 Milliarden
Kubikmeter die es jedes Jahr aus
Russland bezogen hat dauerhaft ersetzen
kann das Ziel ist es die Lieferung zu
diversifizieren mit den Vereinigten
Staaten wurde bereits ein Deal über den
verstärkten Ankauf von flüssig Erdgas
geschlossen wir United Statement
supply forditional at least fifty
billion cubice Meter auf US LNG until
ready of the Russian Gas going to Europe
today
das Problem ist dass Europa sich nicht
erneut von einem großen Lieferanten
abhängig machen darf und das LNG teurer
ist als Pipeline Gas die Verfügbarkeit
von billiger Energie war bisher einer
der wichtigsten Wettbewerbsvorteile
Europas im Vergleich zu Asien Europa
braucht also Gas aus verschiedenen
Quellen und ja wenn möglich billiges Gas
die beste Möglichkeit für die
Europäische Union zu Ergänzung des LG
Ausländern wie den USA oder Katar sind
daher Pipelines und wo könnten die
herkommen wenn Russland nun mal Tabu ist
entweder aus Nordafrika oder eben aus
jedem Regionen die man mit europäischer
Hochnäsigkeit früher gerne abschätzig
den russischen Hinterhof nannte aus dem
Kaukasus und Zentralasien und jetzt
wird's knifflig
allerdings lauern auf die Europäer genau
in dieser Region auch eine Menge
Probleme schauen wir uns diese doch mal
etwas näher an
ich liefere den Kaviar du die Dosen
Aserbaidschan wird seit einem halben
Jahrhundert von derselben Familie
beherrscht den allies im eigenen Land
regiert der Clan mit eiserner Faust aber
gegenüber Außenstehenden ist er sehr
bemüht positiven Eindruck zu schenken
vor allem wenn er sich bei den
Außenstehenden um Europäer handelt denen
ist der Umgang mit Diktaturen ja
bekanntlich nie richtig angenehm also
setzte man in Baku etwas in Gang das
unter einem schönen Begriff ins
internationale politische Wörterbuch
eingegangen ist die K wie eine plomatie
denn mit richtig fett Kohle und feinem
schwarzen Kaviar ist es nun mal
einfacher Freunde zu finden ach ja und
äußerst attraktive Frauen halten auch
dabei kurzum aserbaidschan hat sich
nicht gescheut europäische Politiker zu
kaufen Brüssel ging sogar so weit
Politikern waren Hinweise der Folgen
dazukommen zu lassen seit auf der Hut
wenn ein hübsches Mädchen aus Baku auf
dich zukommt und schmachtend etwas sagt
wie ich will wissen wie lang deine
Pipeline ist dann passt völlig auf sie
ist gar nicht auf echte Freundschaft aus
denn Liebe Abgeordnete spitzenbeamt und
Diplomaten sie will euch rumkrie
Abpressen Aserbaidschan zu unterstützen
okay aber was sind denn die Interessen
Aserbaidschans nun schauen wir uns mal
auf einer Karte an
[Musik]
es geht um diese Pipeline Trasse dabei
wurde viel Gegendruck ausgeübt damit
dieses Projekt in der Schublade bleibt
Russland gegen so weit das ist
politische Parteien in Europa wie die
italienische fünf sternebewegung
finanzierte um den Bau der Pipeline zu
verhindern schließlich wurde der letzte
Teil des südlichen gaskorridors die TAB
die Trans Adria Pipeline im Dezember
2020 in Betrieb genommen dadurch kann
Aserbaidschan derzeit 10 Milliarden
Kubikmeter Gas nach Europa verkaufen im
Vergleich zu den 150 Milliarden
Kubikmetern die bislang aus Russland
kamen ist das ein Klacks alles
Entscheidende ist dass sich das Blatt
gewendet hat denn aufgrund des
russischen Kriegs in der Ukraine sind es
ist die Europäer den Aserbaidschan um
mehr Gas betteln Brüssel hat bereits ein
Abkommen mit Aserbaidschan geschlossen
und die Gaslieferung bis 2027 zu
verdoppeln von der Leyen reiste dazu
sogar nach Baku womit sie dass sie mit
Alice auf keiner schlechteren
Wellenlänge liegt als zum Beispiel mit
Joe
bidension of the southern Gas corridor
and we will expandeds kapazity to twenty
billion Kubikmeters in AF you years from
next your on we should a ready weach 12
billion Kubikmeters this will help
compensate for cuts in supplies of
Russian Gas aber freu dich nicht zu früh
denn auch mit 20 Milliarden Kubikmetern
kann Italien nicht versorgt werden die
bittere Realität des südlichen
gaskorridors ist nun mal er bringt nur
sehr wenig Gas nach Europa und selbst
wenn man seine Leistung bis 2027
verdoppelt wird es immer noch zu wenig
sein aber werfen wir nun einen
gesonderten Blick auf die tarnup die
Trans anatolische Pipeline
die 1.840 km lange kanap wird an der
Grenze Zug Georgien mit
aserbaidschanischem Gas gespeist und
befördert es quer durch die gesamte
Türkei zurück griechischen Grenze wo
liegt diese Pipeline die größtenteils
dem aserbaidschanischen
Staatsunternehmens gehört hat eine
Kapazität von 16 Milliarden Kubikmetern
von den 6 in der Türkei bleiben zwei in
Griechenland und 8 nach Italien gelangen
aber aufgepasst diese Pipeline ist als
skalierbare Pipeline konzipiert das
heißt ihre Kapazität kann durch das
Hinzufügen von parallelen
leitungssträngen und mehr Leistung eine
Pumpstationen erweitert werden konkret
bedeutet es dass sie mit einer
begrenzten Investition von etwa 7
Milliarden Dollar auf eine Kapazität von
32 Milliarden Kubikmeter anwachsen
könnte so weit so gut aber Moment mal
war da nicht irgendwas wollte sogar vor
zehn Jahren nicht noch 60 Milliarden
Kubikmeter transportieren weil das wäre
dann wirklich eine große Sache und da
stellt sich die Frage warum macht
Aserbaidschan das nicht einfach
[Musik]
nun wie so oft liegt es am Geld denn es
kostet schon eher witzige Summen
Gasfelder überhaupt zu erschließen
Schaden ist das aserbaidschanische
megavorkommen hat eine Investition von
sage und schreibe 27 Milliarden Dollar
erfordert um derzeit 21 Milliarden
Kubikmeter pro Jahr fördern zu können
das ist eine Summe um locker 70
vollwertig ausgestattete Kliniken zu
bauen und eben auch der Moment in dem
Aserbaidschan zu Europa sagt liebe
Ursula wir liefern gern den Kaviar aber
kümmerst du dich bitte mal um die Dosen
Präsident Ali f die Steigerung der
Gasexporte erfordert Investitionen und
Garantien alias Botschaft ist klipp und
klar wenn Europa mehr Gas will sollen
seine Energiekonzerne ins Land kommen
und in Aserbaidschan erst einmal kräftig
investieren bedeutet das etwa dass jenes
Aserbaidschan das früher um europäische
Politiker mit hübschen Mädchen Boote
sich jetzt schnöde abwendet nun es gibt
drei Gründe warum bakuum misstrauisch
gegenüber den langfristigen Absichten
Europas ist erstens fürchtet man das ist
genug Kunde geht weshalb Europa wieder
Gas aus Russland kaufen könnte es
könnten ja tausend Dinge passieren Putin
könnte in der Ukraine zur Vernunft
kommen und Einlenken Putin könnte die
Gashand wieder aufdrehen Putin könnte
gar nicht bestürzt werden eigentlich ist
ja alles möglich Aserbaidschan misst
traut Europa und Europa traut
Aserbaidschan auch nicht recht über den
Weg macht es überhaupt Sinn nicht mehr
auf den bösen Putin zu setzen sondern
dafür auf den auch irgendwie bösen ali
ist der nicht nur ein Diktator ist
sondern auch noch das kleine Armenien
nebenan attackiert denn hätten die
Europäer nicht vielleicht sogar bessere
Alternativen als Aserbaidschan nun diese
schauen wir uns jetzt etwas genauer an
das Paradies auf der Gasblase
könnt ihr euch ein Land vorstellen
dessen Gasreserven fünf Mal größer sind
als die Aserbaidschans dieses Land ist
absolute real auch wenn Bilder von dort
manchmal wirken die Märchen aus Tausend
und einer Nacht es heißt Turkmenistan
der Wüstenstaat ist eine richtig
knallharte Diktatur trotzdem verfügt
rückministan diese orientalische
funkversion von Nordkorea international
über ein wesentlich besseres renomme
denn seine Diktatoren stecken das Geld
ihres Landes lieber in vergoldete
reiterstatuen und nicht in Atombomben
und Raketen die Meister Kim der neue
Diktator wird Ministers ist jedenfalls
dieser junge Herr den ihr hier seht sera
Verdi muharedov er hat das Amt von
seinem Vater übernommen und der war der
mit dem besonders schwer
auszusprechenden Namen man normal werden
sich viele von euch jetzt sagen noch so
eine erbliche Diktatur hören wir denn
nie damit auf mit solchen Leuten
Geschäfte zu machen nun ja wenigstens
ist dort ministan eine Diktatur die
offenbar nicht die Absicht hat jemanden
zu überfallen die turkmenischen
Streitkräfte verstehen sich diesem Video
zur Folge vielleicht sogar besser aufs
antanzen als aufs angreifen
[Musik]
das reißt einen ja richtig mit kurzum
tut mindestens erscheint uns zwar
reichlich schräg ist kapselt sich auch
von seinen Nachbarn massiv ab aber es
verbreitet in Zentralasien keinerlei
Angst und Schrecken die Europäische
Union könnte und sollte sich dort also
um eine ähnliches Abkommen bemühen wie
es China erreicht hat das erreicht damit
er sagte zu drücken Istan Werte drücken
ihnen bleibt ganz entspannt wir werden
das Gasfeld selbst erschließen und euch
auch die Gaspipeline bauen und ihr
bezahlt uns für die von uns erbrachten
Leistungen einfach mit eurem Gast ne
wenn das kein Grund für einen kleinen
kolbentanz ist und wenn ihr euch jetzt
fragt warum ist Europa nicht schon
früher auf diese Idee gekommen nun weil
dafür der Bau einer transpastischen
Gaspipeline notwendig wäre also eine
leistungsfähigen Gasleitung quer durch
das Kaspische Meer
und genau da lag der Hase lange im
Pfeffer das Projekt kam jahrzehntelang
nicht aus den Startblöcken war die
Rechtslage so war dass dazu alle
Anrainer Starten des Kaspischen Meeres
hätten grünes Licht geben müssen und
alleiner sind auch Russland und der Iran
und die blockierten das Vorhaben die
Situation hat sich 2018 geändert als ein
neues internationales Abkommen über den
Rechtsstatus des Kaspischen Meeres
unterzeichnet wurde jetzt wird ein
Abkommen zwischen Aserbaidschan und
rückministan ausreichen um die Pipeline
bauen zu können sein Abschluss erscheint
jetzt auch möglich denn 2021 haben die
beiden Länder einen Dauerstreit um ein
Gasfeld mitten im Kaspischen Meer
beigelegt
Turkmenistan und aserbaidschanlagen
gemeinsam das dostblock fällt im
Kaspischen Meer erschließen aber so oder
so wird es mehrere Jahre dauern bis eine
transkaspische Gaspipeline gebaut wird
wenn sie denn überhaupt zustande kommt
deshalb werden bereits jetzt drei
Alternativen in Betracht gezogen damit
turkmenisches Gas auf dem Weg in die
Europäische Union zunächst einmal
Aserbaidschan erreicht eine Möglichkeit
besteht darin ist in Flüssiggas
umzuwandeln und der Schiff in
aserbaidschanische Häfen zu bringen eine
Option ist der Vorschlag des
US-Unternehmens Trans caspin resource
wenn man eine nur 80 Kilometer lange
Verbindungsleitung zwischen einem
turkmenischen und einem
aserbaidschanischen Gas wird im
Kaspischen Meer verlegt könnte burkh
Mensch ist Gas bereits westwärts fließen
die dritte Möglichkeit ist besonders
originell und vor allem funktioniert sie
bereits eine ihr ist jedoch ein Player
beteiligt mit dem ihr jetzt sicher nicht
gerechnet habt drückt Minister an
beginnt mit Tausch von Gaslieferungen an
Aserbaidschan über Iran im Rahmen dieses
3-wege-abkommens wird durchministan
jährlich 4 Milliarden Kubikmeter in den
Iran Punkten und zwar direkt über dessen
Nordostgrenze im Gegenzug dafür werden
aus den Regionen im Nordwesten des Irans
wo es einerseits Gasvorkommen gibt
ehrlich 4 Milliarden Kubikmeter an
Aserbaidschan liefern sozusagen ein
permanenter gasregentausch
wie du siehst es ist Europa nicht
einfach gasausdrücke mir Distanz zu
beziehen und selbst wenn wir dies kein
Allheilmittel sein aber zugleich wäre
dies auch ein Weg für die Europäer
erstmal einen Fuß in die Tür zu
Zentralasien zu bekommen auch um China
in der Region nicht gänzlich den
Vortritt einzuäumen es würde zudem
bedeuten in den Bereichen Sicherheit und
wirtschaftspunkten indem wir eine
stabile und billige Gasversorgung
sicherstellen den besten bietet sich
also aktuell die einmalige Gelegenheit
in zentrale Asien zur neuen Katze zu
werden oder bleibt Europa lieber
gemütlich stur und in seinem Körbchen
liegen zumindest solange es da so schön
warm ist ich meine so warm ist es da ja
nicht mehr und hinten dauert schon
längst der Dicke chinesische Kater der
die Oberaufsicht über die
zentralasiatischen Mäuse übernehmen
möchte und damit sind wir auch schon bei
den Fragen an Euch meint ihr europa
sollte die transkaspische Pipeline
unterstützen oder gar selbst finanzieren
oder manche eher dass wir uns schon von
genug Despoten und Diktaturen abhängig
gemacht haben deswegen Atomkraft und
erneuerbare Energiequellen die bessere
Alternative zu russischem Gas geben oder
habt vielleicht ganz andere Ideen
hinterlasst bitte eure Antworten und
Vorschläge unten in den Kommentaren
abgemacht wir sehen uns dann bald denn
ihr habt visualpolitik die ihr ja schon
sicher abonniert und auch das Glöckchen
aktiviert um kein Video von uns zu
verpassen nicht wahr falls nicht dann
holt das jetzt aber schnell nach ach ja
und ihr habt diesen Video doch bestimmt
schon ein Like gegeben schon allein weil
es kassenkontent enthält in diesem Sinne
macht's gut und bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]